you just call author to book with sam
Harris I had Sam on the show a couple
weeks ago it's called Islam and the
future of tolerance so first off I think
people would love to know a little bit
more about the nature of your
relationship with Sam how you guys came
together Sam of course is a devout
atheist you're your practicing Muslim
correct I don't call myself religious
hold it out I'm a Muslim but I wouldn't
want to hold myself up as any form of
standard for anyone to judge the
religion by or anything else well there
you go so that said tell me a little bit
about how you got connected with Sam and
what sort of brought you two together to
really go ahead and start doing things
like this so we Sam and I first met a
few years ago when I came to New York
where I am right now to debate a on
heresy alley and the motion of the
debate was Islam is a religion of peace
and there's something I need to clarify
with that debate mm-hmm is that I've
never believed it say never sorry in my
current incarnation after leaving his
bateria I've not believed that Islam is
a religion of war or peace and this is
something like spending of my dialogue
with Sam I chose the side of that motion
that Islam is a religion of peace
because there was emotion and I had to
choose whether it was a religion of war
or peace and pick aside I think the
emotion was worded incorrectly frankly
um so that you know I I had a religion
of war not peace it's just a religion
religions are interpreted um
but nevertheless I sat on the side that
it was a religion of peace because I
logically reasoned in my mind that if
the majority of Muslims today aren't
jihadist albeit many many many Muslims
you know I'm not you know liberal in the
way I would like they're certainly not
jihadist terrorists and so if religion
is what people make it if it's lamb is
what Muslims interpret it to be then by
definition it's a religion of peace
simply because Muslims by the
overwhelming majority are not terrorists
so I sat on that side of the debate and
I debated a on afterwards we ended up in
the dinner afterwards and and Sam
happened to be there and I hadn't met
him before and he was called upon by our
eye on to ask me a question and he asked
me you know he said look it's all good
and well you being out there and
to present this you to the public about
Islam being this or that but you know
here between us in in the privacy of
this of this dinner can't you just be
honest with us and tell us that you know
what you really think about this line is
about religion so I might video reaction
it was to say to him are you accusing me
of lying um what you mean can I not be
honest with you are you implying that I
wasn't honest outside there on that you
know on the platform yeah and it became
a very hostile exchange which ended
there it didn't go any further and
everyone was a bit embarrassed around
the table we didn't really develop
beyond that at that point and then we
didn't speak for a couple of years um
and and so then Sam reached out to me
when I think um he'd watched me at the
Richmond forum when I was reunited again
where they are this time
the good thing was it wasn't a debate it
was a conversation and that's actually
the Richmond probably want to thank if
the people from the Richmond forum are
watching this I want to thank them
because the the format that they got the
same moderator John Donvan to the
moderated the debate at the intelligent
squared exhausting earlier occasion um
but instead they got a on myself and
Imam Rolf who had been the the Imam of
the main manhattan mosque and instead of
having a motion to debate they just said
all of you just want we only have to
have a conversation so that really
allowed for me to be in the middle
because he mazzaroth was arguing Islam
as a religion of peace I almost arguing
it's not that it's a religion of war
instead and allowed me in the center to
say guys you know actually ions got
something right you've got something
right there's actually something in the
middle here and that's that I think that
conversation really set the precedent
for what happened with Sam and me
afterwards because I think he saw that I
think a arm was really impressed with
know that the the tone that I took with
her in that conversation and I was
really happy with the result in the way
which we she reciprocated my overtures
to have and I think that really made the
foundations for what happened next and
then Sam reached out to me and said hey
can we kind of have that type of
conversation for my blog
um this is you know he interviews people
on his podcast he publishes it on his
blog so I said well yeah sure and we've
sort of had this some exchange over the
phone and he transcribed it and I said
Sam this is actually really good
think you should put on your blonde I
actually sense this is a book that gets
you know that could really influence a
lot of people and so then he approached
Harvard and thank God the
editor-in-chief of Harvard agreed and
that's the story of the book which hits
the shelves in a week yeah so so we'll
talk about more about Sam in a second
but I think something interesting that
you said about ayaan is that so I think
a lot of your critics or a lot of the
people that are critical of everyone on
your your side of this is that that you
guys all think exactly the same thing
but so I'm fascinated that so you and I
on actually don't agree on certain
elements of this well you see that's the
laziness and the knee-jerk reaction the
emotional reaction which is born of fear
the fear of dialogue and the fear of
actually having conversations with
people that we may disagree with is that
actually the best way to ignore the
consequences that dialogue can work is
to tarnish everyone with a setting brush
yeah and it's to
in fact affectively slander everyone um
yeah and that way that we are justifying
to ourselves and those who are listening
to us why dialogue isn't a good thing
the truth is that um even after this
dialogue listen there are probably many
things that he and I don't see
eye-to-eye on and we they are as well
right and but the important thing is in
recognizing that dialogue is a process
it's not a union just snap your fingers
and somebody agrees with you um and
democracy itself by the way liberal
democracies weren't born in a day the
reason why we use the word mature
democracies when we refer to countries
like the United States the United
Kingdom is because they've had centuries
over over which time they've matured and
that's what the use that analogy that's
exactly what a dialogue with people you
disagree with is it matures over time
right so there's been a bunch of people
you can name them if you like we've
talked about them a lot here and I'm
almost I'm almost tired of talking about
them at this point who are writing some
pretty horrific things about you you
know the worst kind of slanderous stuff
calling you names that if anyone on the
right called you they'd be condemned and
rightfully so and I'm seeing so much of
this coming from the left and these are
the people who I thought would be the
ones
standing up for all the things that
you're talking about here the words that
you're talking about conversation
liberalism all of these things and
you're getting it from the left what do
you make about that
so you know let's move away from the
individuals and and and look at the
movement and and you know the
individuals at the end of the day you
know they whatever they say about me and
wherever they are and have used they
certainly won as bad as I was when I was
a revolutionary Islamist so I hope they
can change oh you're a good guy
you're a good way well I believe in
change and I hope that you know people
at that turning phase if they do change
their views I'd be perfectly happy to
continue being friends with them reza
aslan used to sit on my organization's
board in london as a member of our
advisory council and we disbanded it two
years into founding our organization so
it hasn't existed for about five years
but you know we used to know the guy we
invited him to London for our he's
spoken at my offices in London at
Quilliam so you know people change and
I'm hoping and I'm hoping that you know
we can resume a cordial form of
relationship with all of these guys and
you know I just think that if I can if I
can be go from where I was to where I am
I have faith in humanity but it but it
is important to talk about the concept
because that's the only way people do
change by the way is well has happened
with me is when those ideas are
challenged in a way that tries and it's
difficult we're all human beings we all
have emotions we all have egos but in a
way to challenge those ideas without
making about the ego but actually just
really making about the concepts
themselves and so what you've referred
to is what I've come to refer to as the
regressive left and and then what I mean
by the regressive left is because there
you know not all people on the left wing
are regressive leftists are just like
not all Muslims are Islamists and so
what I mean by the regressive left
Arthur is this phenomenon of people on
the left wing of the debate who who see
between their duty their ideological
duty to challenge
foreign policy mistakes American and
British foreign policy mistake so what
they interpret as colonialism at knio
knio clone neoconservatism they see it
as their duty to challenge this and then
they see another
which is theocracies and and you know
the Islamist ideology and they they have
come to the they've come to the to the
view that you can't challenge both of
these together because if you want to
challenge Islamist theocracy you're
you're supporting neoconservative
foreign policy so they in their minds
they prioritized they've said you know
neoconservative foreign policy the
bigger evil organized violence and chaos
in the form of military invasions is
worse than randomized non-state actor
violence and chaos so we're going to go
after they believe they're engaged in a
war we're going to go after the this is
their mindset we're going to go after
the organized violence and the reason
why sometimes you see duplicity in their
statements is because they genuinely
believe it's an ideological war and so
it's necessary to even engage in
propaganda to defeat this bigger evil
that we believe in which is the
organized violence of war now and so why
are call them regressive is because in
doing so they make alliances with some
of the most regressive yeah theocratic
fascist totalitarian barbaric murdering
and justifies of murderous regimes
across the world right so you know
whether it's Hezbollah a terrorist
organization that's currently fighting
alongside the dictator are certain to
fight with against the Syrian people and
the reason I use the example of his mom
are because the man has just been
elected to the Labor Party leadership in
the United Kingdom who's uh who's
actually born of this regressive left
phenomenon as has been historically has
been very close to groups such as
supporters of groups such as Hezbollah
and that's why I'm citing this example
so whether it's Hezbollah or whether
it's Hamas you know on the one hand I
can see the frustration of people who
want a two-state solution sure which
includes a secure free and independent
Israel and a secure and free and
independent Palestine but that
frustration shouldn't legitimize the
supporting an organization that has at
the heart of its policy the
legitimization of targeting civilians
and so what's happened is why I call
them regressive is that they've allied
in their anti colonial prioritization
with
the most regressive theocratic
organizations that are out there in the
world and then and then and then they
fear they feel that anyone who who
criticizes those organizations is by
definition with the neoconservatives so
they must attack them and that's what's
going on and I take the view actually
you can criticize I I opposed the Iraq
war and the invasion of Iraq from my
jail cell in Egypt I have never
supported the invasion of Iraq I've
never supported New York conservativism
and a member of the Liberal Democrats in
the UK I've never been a member of any
conservative party I've never been a
conservative or supporter of wars in
that sense in my life so so you can
oppose those things at the same time you
can oppose three aquatic fascism you
know we can have two thoughts at the
same time and it's not impossible to do
and I encourage everyone to try it yeah
I love how you wrap that together
because you're right it's two thoughts
at the same time and when I talked about
this with Sam you know he was saying
that they want to find this nugget in
you and once they find this thing that
they say you have not that you say you
have it but that they say you have then
it's somehow discounts every other
liberal principle that you have which is
why suddenly I'm hearing from them that
they'll call Bill Maher is suddenly a
neocon Bill Maher who has I think stood
for every liberal principle been against
every war that I can possibly think of
and I have a suspicion that
unfortunately what these guys are doing
I think for the reasons that you laid
out very well I think they're actually
strengthening the extremists on both
sides right because they're
strengthening the Islamist extremists
because they're not challenging them and
then they're strengthening the the
secular extremists because they're
saying they're making it seem like
there's this one set of ideas that can't
be talked about and secular people want
to talk about all ideas right well if we
if we are not come to refer to this as
the the Voldemort effect you know it's
the it's that the Harry Potter books in
which I'm Jay okay it she devices really
clever mechanism but the people in the
story are so fearful of the evil
Voldemort the two things happen one they
can't they don't recognize believe
Voldemort these actual
they think he's dead and they refused to
admit except anyone
there's telling him a voter what still
lives and the second is that they're so
petrified on this folder who they
believe is dead that they can't even
name him so they refer to him as he who
must not be named so that's what I mean
is that the Voldemort effect and that
leads to you know when you can't name
something that actually is staring you
at you in the face and you're so scared
of it that you deny exists and you don't
want to name it um that increases the
hysteria so you know when present that
says we must defeat the evil ideology
well achievable ideology right you know
and so then the average dude that stands
up in Donald Trump's from Grant rally
and says when are we going to deal with
America's Muslim problem or Carson who
says you know he doesn't want a Muslim
president when they say these things
because the evil ideology when they hear
that word what they mean by that is
Islam and by default every Muslim who
identifies with Islam yeah which is why
they don't want a Muslim president so
what we're doing is by blurring those
lines we're increasing the hysteria and
actually the fit and the bigotry that
we're trying to avoid so what I argue is
for those two reasons and actually more
importantly to empower reforming Muslim
voices within Muslim communities because
the first victims of theocratic fascism
will be those Muslims themselves it will
be the Muslim women it will be the the
minorities of the Yazidi women it will
be the Coptic Christians in Egypt it
will be their liberal Muslims will be
the apostates the X Muslims it will be
the gay Muslims and the lesbian Muslims
these are the ones who first suffer nor
under the yoke of the aquatic fascism we
need to also provide them with a lexicon
that they can deploy in their own
internal reform debates so if you don't
if you don't recognize Islamism what are
they going to say is the problem when
they're having these debates within
their communities Islam the religion
that's going to get them killed
immediately in the first place aside
from the you know the intellectual point
that what do you mean by Islam the
religion it's interpreted in a million
different ways down that that's such a
good handle on why this is so difficult
because we're talking about ideas we're
talking about people we're talking about
religion we're talking about political
movements it's just so much at once so
just to sort of read just to bring
around this this part of it
in terms of dealing with these people
the people that have been writing all
these things and all that how how
personally exhausting is it for you
because I see and I've read you know
where Sam has said you know he's not
going to do this anymore and he said to
me even that then suddenly it's like he
has to say something because it's not
fun being lied about or slandered or
smeared and and as I said before you in
a way get it worse a tweet by one of
these guys just this week to you was
about how he's going to report you to
the Department of Homeland Security when
you come to the United States because he
doesn't want annex terrorists here I
mean this is really horrible stuff how
do you just deal with it on the personal
level it's exhausting right you see the
the the thing with this tweet is it
really raises an interesting insight and
again you know I hope this guy really
changes his approach to this but um the
interesting thing this raises is is a
liberal guy who ostensibly opposes
profiling at airports okay which by the
way I've always done
I've always been I'm not you can find
more that I've done against profiling
any of these voices if you google google
maids on YouTube there's a whole debate
on that on BBC Newsnight which is a
flagship news show in the UK against the
left wings Labour Party member of
Parliament's who also happens to Muslim
who was advocating profiling five years
ago and I was debating him on that
saying you know this is a silly idea so
I've always been against profiling but
so was this guy who send the tweet you
just referred yeah yeah what's what's
interesting is suddenly when somebody is
breaking out of the group think think
and dis associating themselves with the
tribal identity that you that we use to
to have this us in them kind of gain
that we refer to earlier that you know
you're either with the neocons or you're
with us and that kind of us and them
relies on this tribal identity when
someone breaks free from that tribal
identity refuses to belong here or there
suddenly you find it's open season that
all the principles that we use to
actually tarnish the neocons
oh it's the neo-cons we want to profile
Muslims it's the neocons who are racist
we're using that same racism against
those dissenting voices I was called a
porch monkey right I was called a native
informant I was called a house Muslim by
white naan
in this instance absolutely reputable
people this isn't just random eggs on
Twitter sayings no no no these are these
are journalists that work for
established organizations at the right
foot establish blogs and then on top of
that you just mentioned somebody saying
I hope the HS reads the department phone
that's given to read your book before
you come to the States because I don't
want an X terrorist coming into the into
the United States and you know I put
aside the fact I was never a terrorist
that's advocating profiling by somebody
who literally a day earlier had been on
CNN accusing Sam Harris of advocating
profiling yeah and so it's suddenly what
happens is when you break away from that
group kind of tribal group think it
becomes open season and that's why I
said earlier that I think what's going
on here is they genuinely believe
they're engaged in a war and so in a war
all of these tactics become legitimate
because the objective is to win it's not
to find the truth and I think that's
part of the problem that's why I think
this dialogue and this conversation is
so important yes because what we do is
we break down that hostility so I keep
referring that's why actually it's a
lesson to myself as well it's so
important to remain polite with these
guys because whatever they say to me if
I if I reinforce their their notion that
they've somehow managed to convince
themselves of that that this is a war
and if I respond in that manner they
will double down and they will continue
to ask this as a war and that anything
is is is permissible yeah so you know
that's why I try and and deescalate it
and I fail sometimes but I you know it's
important for me to keep trying yeah I
feel the same way I try as well from the
little piece of this that I'm part of
and I've tried to engage some of these
people in a respectful way and
unfortunately you know as Sam is
illustrated quite well it's hard to
debate when you have your facts and then
the person you're debating is debating
what they think you say or what they
want you to say not not what you what
you actually say